hi everyone good afternoon
i'm michelle from design singapore
council welcome to the design thinking
for business transformation webinar
so this webinar is organized by design
support console
in collaboration with sbf and then just
want to run us through again
to uh for today's program lineup uh we
will have tamzin
um director of school of eggs from
design support council to share
more about design thinking 101 and then
next i'll be doing a short 10 minute
sharing on some of the useful schemes
businesses can embark on with respect to
improving customer experience or driving
innovation
and then we'll be followed by the
sharing of two companies
photohub and the pro group on their
experience from the onboarding of such
schemes
and then we'll close it off with uh q a
but before we begin i'd like to
hand the time now over to karen from sbf
who will share with us
some of the new programs and updates
that they have
with you karen hi good afternoon
everyone
to all participants on this call i can
see there are quite a few of you out
there
i'm karen from the membership and tac
engagement division of sbf
and we handle all membership matters and
we work with government agencies
and our partners to bring initiatives
that would support
business growth and capability upgrading
my team also administers a program for
sbf members known as the
rising and support of enterprises
program or rise
for short which was launched back in
july so
you may be wondering how is this
relevant to what you're going to be
listening to today
well on the next slide um today you'll
be learning
actually more about how design thinking
can help you to improve your customer
experience and
identify new areas of growth design
singapore council will share actually
two important schemes that
you can take advantage of to embark on
this journey for your business and the
first is actually user journey mapping
and the second frame in scope um
these programs have subsidies of up to
80 which you can receive from the
government
i'm happy to share that both of these
schemes have just been included for
additional funding under sbs rise
program
and because it's a very new development
you will not currently find
information on rise funding in the web
pages
for these two schemes but that will soon
be updated and also
likewise we would be reflecting these
two programs in sbs rise web page if
you've
gone over to our website now both of
these
schemes i actually considered business
growth activities under rise
if you're an eligible sbf member you can
claim a one-time
support of up to five hundred dollars on
the unsubsidized portion
of project costs that are incurred um
you would have to
complete either of these programs first
of course
um on the next page um just wanted to
give you some background about the rise
program
um some of you may have already heard
the rise program was set up by
sbf to help businesses transform and
emerge
stronger arising from a lot of the covet
challenges that we all face today
um but it it by making it more
affordable
for businesses to participate
in uh capability upgrading or business
growth activities
so there's actually a wide range of
activities
that companies can participate in and
this now includes the two
two schemes that was mentioned earlier
um if you look at the third column
to qualify for rise support uh companies
must fulfill four
criteria um and this is that you have to
first be an sbf member
with no outstanding membership fees ever
paid up capital
not exceeding five million and since the
program
provides a one-time support the
companies must not have previously
already enjoyed
ryze support um this program runs until
the end of next year
or until the rise fund is exhausted
whichever comes
earlier on the last slide um
i just want to encourage everyone on
this call to check out the details of
the rise program
after today's session because in that
website it tells you how you can apply
for that support
also after the session a link to our web
page and
our contact information that you see
here on the page will be shared with you
through
an edm so if you have any questions
please do not hesitate to reach out to
us
on this note i would like to thank
design singapore council
for this opportunity to share with you
on this program and let me turn the time
back to michelle
thank you karen now i'd like to hand the
time to tamzin we'll run us through the
introduction of design thinking
so you learn about the key stages of
design thinking as well as some of the
case studies of how companies have
successfully adopted this methodology
for their businesses
over to you themselves so good afternoon
everybody i hope you've had a great day
good start to the week
i have a very short amount of time to
share with you something that i've got a
lot of passion for and
that i have been using in one way or
another for the past almost 30 years
to truthfully transform expectations and
outcomes of even very large scale
complex programs
i before i moved to singapore i moved to
singapore around eight years ago
i was i was part of the senior
leadership team for the largest civil
engineering project in the uk at the
time
it was mired in controversy and we
basically use a design thinking led
approach to transform literally
transform the outcomes of that project
so design thinking is something
truthfully you can apply to almost any
complex challenge
i now have the challenge of taking you
through that in around 30 minutes to
give you a taster of what it looks like
in practice
share a few little examples of how
people have used it and
and why it helps um but but i'm very
conscious i'm not going to cover
everything so i'm sure you'll have
questions at the end please do feel free
to reach out
so first of all a little bit about
design singapore council for those who
who don't know much about
it it's their national agency for design
and in fact i may be not well placed to
really describe design singapore council
because i'm a real newbie
i joined design singapore council slap
bang in the middle of circuit breaker
phase one so that's been an interesting
journey
um but in a nutshell design singapore
council has
um its mission to develop the design
sector for singapore and as i say i've
seen design used in such powerful ways
around the world
that i'm very passionate about enabling
singapore and every sector of life from
business through to domestic side of
life
to really leverage that potential
we focus our work in three areas so we
really look at how we can help
organizations to use design as a
strategic business tool
to to really leverage some of those
opportunities i've talked about so not
just the commercial organizations but
also to try to really drive
citizen-centered public services and
also to build
design talent across the workforce and
into the community
so that we start to have more confidence
in creative problem solving and
see new opportunities where where
challenges face us
and then a part of that is really about
raising the singapore brand and
projecting the soft power that singer
has in
singapore has an association with that
um and for those who aren't aware we sit
within the economic development board
and very very briefly our big vision is
under our design master plan
to create an innovation driven economy
and a lovable city by design with
some of those benefits that are listed
out there on screen
we have five three uh five key strategic
thrusts that are helping us to move in
that direction
and strategic trust number one i shall
mention briefly because that's the one i
focus
mainly on which is infusing design
international skill set
i firmly believe that every single one
of us has a designer in us we all have
some design ability
um for those of you who enjoy watching
football i'm british so of course it's
hard wired into me
the analogy might be the difference
between david beckham
or manchester united and the sunday
league team or the
other people that kick about to football
in the park on a sunday afternoon
every single one of them plays football
but we just have different levels of
capability
my belief is that design is exactly the
same we will always have master
designers who are geniuses and produce
these amazing things for us
but actually all of us have the ability
to design and it's an extremely powerful
skill set
so this is why i'm very passionate about
building design into the national skill
set
and and my little school that i just
have to do a little plug for because hey
i've got the stage now
it's called school of x and school of x
is something quite new it's a real world
learning platform
that brings organizations together with
different kind of stakeholders so we
bring a very diverse lens of problem
solvers together
to tackle shared challenges um so the
challenges might be how might we
reimagine our heritage neighborhoods who
are really struggling at this
during this pandemic how might we really
look at the different users in the
neighborhood and reimagine the use of
the space so that all stakeholders can
thrive we do this by building people's
design
skills helping them to understand how to
build a human centered design
lens so there are learning outcomes for
everyone that takes part
but crucially we don't have a test we
don't have an assessment the assessment
is can you design a solution to this
challenge
and we coach and mentor you in actually
implementing that solution on the ground
so there's a project outcome and a
learning outcome through school of ex
so there's a little plug michelle is
going to share more on some of the other
programs later but for anyone that's
interested in school of x do feel free
to reach out with me
after today's session so but anyway who
cares about design thinking how this is
just surely some fancy term that we've
heard a lot of
but doesn't really mean anything to us
who are busy doing
normal jobs and trying to earn a living
well actually i really believe design
thinking is
hardwired into the singapore soul
design thinking although it may not have
been called that is really what brought
singapore to where it is today that
vision review of how do we go from the
challenging motivating conditions we're
grappling with on the ground
50-plus years ago to this incredible
country we live in today this this
this city garden this incredibly
innovative place
that makes anything seem possible but
actually design
thinking methodologies and mindsets have
really underpinned a lot of that journey
so design thinking shouldn't be
something that is new to us in singapore
because it's hardwired into the way we
already think and do things
it's also identified as one of the key
critical skill sets
for any organization going through
transformation in particular
minister chan chan singh they're talking
about the the key skill sets for public
service workers design thinking is seen
as one of them
but there have been various pieces of
research that says this
is one of the future proofing skills
that we should all be equipping
ourselves with
and the great secret is it's dead easy
to learn it just is something we keep
practicing so
it's really something that's quite
accessible unlike learning artificial
intelligence engineering a bit more
tricky
so so what is design thinking then
i think very often we assume that we can
ask people what we want and that's good
enough i've often been told by people
well hansen i've been doing design
thinking i asked people what they wanted
and this is what they said but it's not
really design thinking and part of that
is because we don't always consciously
realize what it is we want
uh we don't always know the answer to
the problem we're grappling with
traditional market research does tend to
assume that we
know what the problem is we want to
solve and that we know what the solution
would be
so very often you'll see people asking
in surveys
how could we do this better what could
we improve what other things of features
would you like to see
and you put all that burden that
pressure that design pressure on me your
customer
i don't know i just know that this isn't
quite working for me and i'm not quite
sure why it's not working for me
and i'm not quite sure what i want to
see in its place
but it's just not working for me and
then we tend to leave him
so we can usually describe what we want
to achieve but we don't always know
how we need to get there and this is the
famous quote that's often attributed to
henry ford
if i had asked people what they wanted
they would have said faster horses
and i think it perfectly encapsulates i
mean there is a little bit of a
discussion as to whether he actually
said this or not but it doesn't matter
yeah the spirit of it remains absolutely
true
we can only imagine and exaggerated form
of what we're currently experiencing
experiencing usually so actually if we'd
ask the question what is it that you're
trying to achieve and if people
said actually i want to get to places
quicker the horse is too slow
the horse gets tired i have to stop if
we go for too
too long a distance then we start to
open up our design solution options
so just by reframing even the way we ask
people what they want
it can open up different kind of
solutions and design thinking is more
about that
design thinking is about bringing a
different lens to the challenge and
digging beneath the headlines of what it
is our customers are telling us
so it really is bringing a fresh pair of
eyes and ideally multiple
sets of fresh eyes to the challenge
um and the reality is for most of us in
any organization when we look at
designing a new product we usually start
with what it is that we're able to do
or very often in today's world we look
at what our kpis are and how we're going
to achieve them
or sometimes we have an idea that we
personally passionate about and we've
got the opportunity to roll it out and
say to our bosses hey
this helps us achieve our kpi and i'm
really excited about it
great and it's something innovative and
we can afford it so we want to we think
it's worth the investment we want to
rush ahead
and then we rely on great marketing to
make everyone else want it
and i don't know if everyone anyone's
ever heard of aroma vision
i mean i currently see a show of hands
but there was a big trend
i think it began right back at the
beginning of the 20th century
for uh integrating aromas into cinemas
it started with having fans and
cottonwool soaked in rose oil
but eventually it became quite advanced
this particular film
was the first as they call it smelly
movie
it had apparently around 72 cents
integrated into the film
so as you watched the film a different
scent would drop
through the air conditioning units so
that you would be really immersed
into the film and transported to that
place and it had random sense like um
the scent of a captured tiger i have no
idea what that might smell like
um marjon tiles again interesting
and it was really meant to take an
audience behind the the great wall of
china
sounds great how sounds like something
that would come out today
really ahead of its time and that was
part of the problem it was ahead of its
time the technology wasn't great
they hadn't really prototyped it in the
way that you might have done if you'd
adopted a design thinking
approach so people actually found it
just made them feel nauseous it was
overwhelming the smells took a long time
to clear and there was just an overload
to the senses
some people couldn't smell it very well
so they were sniffing loudly to try to
get the scent the whole thing was a bit
chaotic
um and this is where we we see that the
benefit of design thinking could really
have ironed out some of the creases you
might have taken a different approach
and said actually we have got a great
idea and i
still think i would love to see this
happen i can see there's some potential
around this
but how might we make it work well
perhaps you don't need
72 different smells during a film
perhaps actually you bring a scent in at
certain times perhaps actually it's
connected to
the arrival of a certain character that
has some kind of different meaning
perhaps there's different ways of doing
it and
and today with artificial intelligence
perhaps there's different ways of really
personalizing that
so i believe there's potential but the
real thing is before you go and invest
in kitting out an entire movie theater
with this technology and incidentally
this was invented by a marketing
executive
yeah so it didn't come necessarily from
what the the audience wanted it came
from a great idea
to sell seats so again design thinking
might start
in a different way and this might well
have still been the answer but the way
you designed it and delivered it may
have been
done in a different way sadly this this
concept was trashed it didn't really
take off there were many different
versions that were try but it's never
really got any traction
um but let's see maybe it's day has
still to come and if we use a design
thinking approach maybe we really can
get there so i'm just giving that
marketing idea out to all of you there
um
so what does does you know what makes
design thinking different therefore
design thinking doesn't start from the
approach of what we can do
or what we can afford it takes a
slightly different approach in a
nutshell it's a very iterative process
and i'm going to come on to this and i'm
going to come on to this and i don't
want to put you off the process but
iteration is fundamental to the design
thinking process
it's a process for creative problem
solving so if you have a very linear
engineering type problem and i wouldn't
say it's worth using design thinking
at all that would be like using a
sledgehammer to crack open a nut
unnecessary um my aircon broke yesterday
the guys came it was a straightforward
maybe complicated but issue to fix
design thinking is more for complex
issues and usually human centered and it
allows us when we go
through the process to define this sweet
spot between
what's technologically feasible what's
economically viable the business case
and then what's desirable to our
stakeholders either our customers or our
patients or whoever they may be
and desirability is normally i have to
say it's very often added on as an
afterthought how do we package this
market it brand it give it a nice logo
get a social media
campaign running for it how do we make
it attractive once we've designed what
we can do and what we can afford
and that's common sense yeah that makes
sense design thinking
actually flips that model and it starts
by understanding the mindset
and what we call the unmet needs of our
stakeholders
we often think we know our customers but
it might be they're grappling with
things
that they just learned to get by with
imagine if we could overcome some of
those maybe there are things they wish
we were offering
that they haven't thought of and we
haven't thought of and we can actually
start by looking into some of those
unmet needs
they might be pain points or frictions
that they're grappling with that they
just learned to live with
but that actually we could quite easily
design out so we start by really trying
to get beneath the skin of what it is
that's motivating our stakeholders once
we understand them
it then means that we're far more likely
to find
a sustainable and women's solution
something that we can deliver that they
can
and want to use and that we can afford
so we start with desire
and that allows us then to come up with
something that would be more likely to
be sustained
but that's when we go through the full
process
and design thinking is a mess i've just
finished a school of x program
and we take people who haven't had no
exposure to design thinking before in
their life
and quite logical people and they go
through the process and it actually
delights me when
i see those little moments of
frustration and they pull their hair and
say ah
this is so frustrating it feels so messy
but at the end of it they come up with
amazing solutions that they couldn't
have dreamed possible
so we have to kind of embrace the mess
so anyone who has ocd issues yeah it's
something you have to learn to let go of
as you go through the design thinking
process
however that doesn't mean it's fluffy
what it means is you're embracing
the complexity of the problem you're
trying to solve
design thinking allows us to reframe
problems into opportunities and that's
one of the most powerful things it
enables us to do so by going through the
design thinking process
we sometimes start to re-look what it is
we're grappling with and realize
it may not even be a challenge it may be
a great new opportunity
to pivot or to do something more
impactful
the other thing it's very powerful doing
is allowing us to see patterns
we start as we go through the process to
understand the patterns that are
emerging
and to make connections between the
patterns and to
try to draw out insights inside a gold
for us
because it helps us understand why
things happen so the design thinking
process is designed to enable us to go
through and actually unlock insights
that maybe had been hidden in place
plain sight it also challenges our
entrenched assumptions and
over and over again i've been in
situations
where we've really challenged high
high ranking and very professional
experienced people
i took a chief financial officer out to
do some field research once and he had
been very
very adamant to me in advance that he
knew his customers and he said tamsen
you have to understand
i know singaporeans all they're
interested in
is the biggest bargain so we design
everything to be as cheap as possible
that's their biggest motivation and i
said well that's great
i said um have you ever asked them i
said i don't need to i am singaporean i
know
okay so we went out i said this would
just be a validation
and we went out and spoke to people real
people in the field
who really were buying his kind of
services he couldn't find a single
person to validate that assumption
in some things we do want the bargain in
some things
the price point is more important than
other things but in certain services
quality or speed is more important to us
and his particular industry was
healthcare and people when it comes to
health care
are a bit more choosy and the price
point wasn't the critical thing
and it it really blew his mind and he he
couldn't understand that his assumptions
were being challenged in this way but it
was a real breakthrough it actually
allowed him then to move into really
designing a different range of products
it wasn't dropping his products it was
actually expanding out his offering
so this can be very powerful about it um
it's also action oriented it's it's less
about planning
in an ivory tower and pushing things out
it's very
iterative and action focused which means
we learn
quickly and we improve quickly you often
hear the phrase about failing fast in
design thinking well i first
see it as improving fast yeah we're
permanently permanently
how we rub out the friction points it's
very diverse in its inputs
um so we we value those diverse
range of perspectives both in the
research phase understanding our
stakeholders and also in the ideation
phase i'm going to come on to this in a
moment
because this is where we we again
challenge our assumptions but also
open up our opportunities because we
can't possibly
know everything there is available to
know
and this is another big thing it's not
binary so this sometimes is hard for
people to grapple with
we're often told there's one correct
answer my son has just finished uh psle
oh thank goodness um and it was a very
interesting journey for me trying to go
through
for example his science revision i've
had an exhausting journey for both of us
and i realized i had to kept i had to
keep stopping him from thinking
as we were going through revision papers
and as anyone whose child's been through
uh psle will have known
we go through a million old test papers
yeah
and my son kept coming up with
alternative scenarios ah but
if it was at night time the plant would
be doing this ah but if it was this kind
of crustacean it would be doing this oh
but i said whoa
stop and pierce ely there is one correct
answer focus on that forget all the
other things here
and for all of us that go through school
we've
had a similar experience we're taught to
block out complexity and focus
on a more accessible and manageable
version of what we're facing
and actually design thinking opens that
back up again and says you know there's
not always
one answer there's usually multiple
possible options and it's for us to test
and work out which of those is the
optimal one
and this is sometimes very challenging
for people
it runs on rapid prototyping as i've
mentioned in terms of the iteration
we're quickly testing changing improving
and really physically engaging with our
idea
so we can see how to make it better and
it's really intended for wicked problems
and wicked problems are usually problems
that have human
beings in the heart of them because
human beings we're not logical
for all the engineers listening now
they're saying well i'm very logical
actually even engineers are not always
logical
human beings are driven more by emotion
than they are logic and we normally post
validate with logic
so when we're in that kind of scenario
when we roll out very logical solutions
for human beings who are not always
driven by logic
that's sometimes why we can get sticking
points
there um there are numerous um
frameworks and models for design
thinking and i'm not going to go through
them all
um you'll be glad to know but i thought
i will very briefly introduce you to the
overall
kind of process that's common to go
through with design thinking um
and it always starts by understanding
our user by
understanding the challenges on the
ground and i'm going to quickly run
through what i mean by all of these
these little buttons in a minute this
allows us to
then frame out the problem um as as
albert einstein is believed to have said
if he had an hour to save the world he
would spend 55 minutes
working out what the problem was that
needs to be sold and then he could solve
it in five minutes well i'm a firm
believer in that
if you frame your challenge correctly
everything else will fall into
place the problem is we normally skimp
on this part because we think we should
focus on having lots of great ideas
framio challenge is an important part of
the design process it's informed by the
empathy-based research we do
um but after we framed a challenge and
we think actually now i know what
problem it is that i'm trying to solve
and very often we find we were trying to
solve the wrong problem and that's why
we weren't really getting anywhere
this little word at the bottom iterate
comes into play
we've reframed our challenge and that
actually means probably we need to go
and do a little bit more research now to
better understand that
aspect of the challenge when we really
understand the problem we're trying to
solve it then becomes
super easy to generate ideas truthfully
you'll know it you won't be able to stop
yourself you'll have more ideas you can
possibly
than you can possibly ever roll out and
that's when you know you're on the right
track
of course your challenge is you can't
deliver all of those ideas so you then
have to synthesize them into the most
impactful ones and design thinking
process
allows for that it allows you to connect
the dots between the challenge you've
identified
the users that you're trying to engage
and then
the solution that's most likely to work
but of course as we go through the
ideation process it may
help us rethink again about what the
challenge is so we may have a little bit
more iteration
once we've got this idea up we really
need to think about how we can test it
with people before we go out and spend
three million dollars rolling it out
into a movie theater
so we build visual prototypes and we get
people to give us their feedback on them
and again with the prototypes it's where
we better understand what we mean by our
idea
we then refine the idea further and
eventually we get out and we test it
with real users
so we'll be looking at how we can test
both both the concept
and how people would interact with it
100
that means we yet again need to iterate
and improve so that by the time we get
to roll out our solution we've ironed
out a lot of the kinks and we've got
something very very powerful
you'll normally be at the phase then
where your users are begging you for it
they're saying when can i buy one of
these so you'll know that you're on the
right track then
so in a nutshell that's how it works
lots and lots of iteration but don't
fear that it's part of the process
and it actually means that at every
single stage you're refining your
concept in something that's far more
powerful and effective
how does it look in practice well to
understand our users
we can't do that in isolation we can't
do that by sending out a survey form
we need to go out and actually look at
them using
our products and services or our
competitors or using the space that
we're interested in
and we really need to learn to look at
behaviors of interactions
we try to look at emotions and draw what
we can from that
we look at hacks and workarounds you can
see here this is a photo taken from a
brand new um
tollbooth station it's thanking you all
new technology
and the worrying thing is that already
after it had been opened
um the organization had to print out
an important notice to tell people how
to use the booth
and then even worse than that because
people weren't paying attention to the
formal poster
someone had to do a handwritten note to
re-emphasize it
in design research terms we would look
at this and think something's not
working here
yeah this might be a sign that we need
to go in and think about how else we
might solve this problem
so when we go out we really try and look
for little clues that are there
in the environment and in our users
behaviors so we can better understand
what what it is we're designing to
achieve we ask questions and when we ask
questions they're not binary we're not
saying to people tell us what the
problem is and tell me how to fix it
the easiest way is to draw out people's
user experiences their stories and
to try to understand why so why they do
that why do they feel like that
um and to really then walk in the shoes
of our users
i always do this in my projects number
one because i'm very nosy
um but also because nothing can replace
this yeah that experience of walking
around seeing what it's actually like to
engage with our products and services
is very powerful and particularly if you
don't do it very often
so when i've worked with some
organizations i'll force them to go out
and
and use their own services and very
often in the senior management team they
they've never used the services so it's
a powerful place to be
i'm going to try and share a quick video
to give you an example of of how this
might look in
practice this is an empathy based
research but it helps you understand the
benefit
of trying to look at the full picture
during research phase
an event seen from one point of view
gives one
impression
seen from another point of view it gives
quite a different impression
but it's only when you get the whole
picture you can fully understand
what's going on okay so just a quick
little video there to share
i i don't have time to ask you to turn
on your cameras and have a chat although
i wouldn't really love to do that
but it it really helps us to see that
sometimes if we do a shallow level of
research we can jump to the wrong
conclusion
when we look at our situation from
different lenses it helps us to better
understand the problem
so it doesn't mean that our first
assumption was wrong but it might help
to give us a better appreciation of
really what's going on
in order to then design a solution for
it so the empathy phase is
critical and we keep it's something we
never drop we keep bringing it back into
every single thing that we're doing
in terms of defining the challenge um
i'm just checking the time there okay um
we then go through trying to define the
challenge we look for patterns and this
again takes a bit of practice but as you
go through you'll start to pull out
patterns of feedback patterns of
observations
and start to connect the dots between
the the observations you've seen
and people's behaviors and the problem
you're trying to solve
so this allows us then to really focus
in on a specific area and to start to
to draw out a clearer description of our
challenge
now bear in mind as i've mentioned with
iteration the more we research
the more we may need to do more research
as we keep framing our challenge down
more tightly
but we'll eventually reach the point
where we can frame
something around how might we solve this
issue
um and we normally work towards how
might we statement because it's phrased
in such a way that it allows
multiple options to come forward as
potential solutions
i'm going to share a quick example here
of a very well-known cat food company
and this one was it was actually
operating over in europe
they already had around 80 percent of
market share depending on how you ask
the question
but they you know they wanted more of
course they wanted more
so when you've already got 80 percent of
the market buying your cat food how do
you
increase that market share so they did
what what they always did they started
out by
carrying out a survey they wrote out to
their customers they
encouraged people to fill in and the
chance to win some free cat food or
whatever the prize was
and actually all the survey did was
confirm what they already knew because
of course the questions were designed to
confirm that
there wasn't really an opportunity to
dig beneath the surface yes
my cat likes your cat food i know that
because it always clears the bowl
i love my cat it's not a burden to have
a cat i enjoy caring for my cat
no no breakthrough insights so they
decided they needed to run a focus group
or several focus groups
and the focus groups again didn't really
provide any insights i love my cat my
cat's like a member of the family to me
um but there was no insight no
breakthrough
so they asked some families if they
would be prepared to have a video camera
placed in their kitchen for a period of
weeks
i think in this case they probably had
to bribe them with a year supply of free
cat food
so sure and of course the same old thing
happens that's
up during the first week every time the
cat owner walks into the kitchen
they're looking their very best and
they're very conscious of the cameras
but after a while they forget the
cameras are there and the real user
behavior comes out
and as the researchers started to watch
the footage something started to emerge
a pattern emerged
they really hadn't expected 100
they had not put this question on the
survey form and absolutely they hadn't
asked this question
focus groups they noticed that a large
number of the cat
cat owners actually tested the cat food
themselves before they fed it to the cat
ah that wasn't something that they
expected they went back and they asked
the owners why do you do that
some of them weren't even aware they
were doing it it was a subconscious
action
um but for some of them i said well it's
like my baby i want to check the foods
good enough for my baby and the clues
have been there of course this is like a
member of my family
any one of us that has a child knows
that when they're little we've tested
their food before we feed them
so for me the surveys and the focus
groups can be more powerful after we've
done the empathy-based research where we
think wow is this real
could we now send a survey out to find
out how many other people do this
maybe people aren't even aware so maybe
there's a different way we need to draw
this insight out
so the design thinking approach can be
very powerful
in terms of understanding what the
opportunity is
in terms of the ideation there's many
many different ways we can come up with
generating ideas once we frame that
challenge
it becomes super easy and there are
different techniques such as flipping
the problem into a positive it's quite
if you wish to go off and try that
yourself you can
this poster here on the right was one
created by an artist a graphics designer
called ambershare
she looked at um one star or zero star
trip advisor ratings for the national
parks in america she couldn't believe
that people were actually giving such
low ratings to national parks and she
wondered why
and she actually flipped the negative
reviews into advertising posters
so it's an interesting thing for some
people the thought of no cell service no
mobile phone signal
and terrible wi-fi oh my goodness my
teenage children would hate that
but actually for me no one can reach me
for two weeks i'm on holiday
so again we can look at the challenge
and think is there a different way of
approaching this
um and we then synthesize down our ideas
into the one that works most powerfully
for our users
and this is where the value proposition
canvas comes in
through doing our research we begin to
understand our customer or our user
we understand what things they're trying
to get done eg feed the cat
we understand the pain points and we
also understand that get what they're
aiming to try to achieve so you know
the pain points may be oh i don't like
eating my can my cat's food for an
industrial looking can it makes it feel
like he's
less important than the rest of the
family and the cans are really awkward
and clunky to open and i can't get the
food at the bottom
we start to understand the friction
points that we could design out
we also understand that what the person
really wants the cat owner is to make
this
cat feel as welcome in the family as
everyone else to really sit at the table
and be served on a silver platter
and that indeed is how this company
changed its approach to packaging their
cat food
and marketing it um so we can then
connect our idea to what it is that will
really resonate
with our user prototyping then allows us
to design
uh the idea to actually have a visual
and even physical
experience for people to connect to and
give feedback on
it's much easier for people to give
feedback something they can interact
with
and and look at rather than just
something they read about or listen to
and the prototype can be as crude as
this it can start
like a cardboard box with pictures drawn
onto it so
people can be spoken through and have a
go at playing with this imaginary device
you can start in a very accessible and
affordable way
so design thinking need to be expensive
it really can start
cheap and fast and dirty so that you can
just start to improve your understanding
of what people might be looking for we
then can get onto higher levels what
we're really trying to do here is
understand
first of all whether the concept is
something that our users
find appealing and where the strength
points are and where the
things they're less interested are and
then also really look at the usability
that user experience as they're
interacting with it this allows us to
keep improving our concept and we really
we start in a very low fidelity way and
we gradually
build that up as we get more feedback on
board
this is actually an example from a
project this was a couple of weekends
ago
up at the dual at changi airport we took
a group of
staff volunteers and other people who
had been going through a school of x
program
they had designed solutions for dance
for life
and this is actually an example of them
um running some
event up at up at the duel and it's such
an extremely powerful experience because
they could see where the gaps were in
their thinking
and so they also found that it was a
tremendously effective
solution for the challenge they were
looking at but
they really understood how to make that
work better so even if it's a crude and
basic prototype
um the experience of taking your users
through is tremendously powerful
in terms of informing the outcomes these
the people who designed the solutions on
this program went through a six-week
program with us part-time
and by the end of it they've come up
with solutions that dabs for life will
be operationalizing nationally next year
so you can see from a very small project
driven by
non-designers you can actually come up
with something that has
a big impact i'm quickly going to run
through this before i end
i'm very often told by people that they
have many reasons why they don't want to
go down the route of design thinking
um and cost is one of them yeah
why will i waste so much money going
through all these different ideas when i
already can just choose one
so this is again where i show you
cardboard boxes and drawings on
whiteboards it needn't be expensive
to test many ideas yeah and to see which
one gets traction
but the other big thing is it can
actually save you a lot of money i'm
often
brought into projects that have already
gone wrong where a lot of money has been
invested where stakeholders
are feeling disillusioned and they may
even have their reputation damaged
there may even be people protesting
against the solution because it wasn't
thought through well
and i'm often brought in to try to fix
that that's then very expensive to try
to fix the problem that's already
been rolled out so design thinking can
actually save you a lot of money by
using by getting all of the friction out
up front in a very low five way
and it will take too long huh well
actually no we can do this very quickly
i was talking to a project
uh clients this morning the project
they're looking is is
looking at is is transformational it
will be a huge piece of infrastructure
coming into singapore
a big lifestyle investment and we're
looking at doing a four-week program to
iterate and come up with a very powerful
concept right in the heart of that
it can be quick it needn't be time
consuming but it can allow you to make
sure that you're going in the direction
that's going to resonate with the people
that you want to
bring on board so actually it can really
in a long time save time and again it
can avoid you having to spend time
remedying things and this is a common
one we can't please everyone as soon as
we start engaging people and ask them
what they want the last of things we
can't give them
well the design thinking process isn't
really like a checklist to tell me what
you want
it's more processed to uncover the
motivations the aspirations the insights
we focus on the why
you want this rather than the what you
want and this allows us then to design
for the win
win win and i always say we can look not
only for the win win but the multiple
win because
that is the that's the solution that
will already get traction and it's 100
possible
even when it doesn't seem like that
another one is i already know my
customers they're very loyal they've
been using my services for years i don't
need this
okay well i gave you the example of the
cfo already yeah
this gives us a chance to understand the
customers better in an entirely
um integrated world customer
expectations are beginning to change we
expect
more from the people we buy services
from people we transact with people we
engage with
so if we don't keep track of their
motivations and understand what lies
beneath the surface
we may risk losing them at some point
and then this is the other one it's
messy unfocused well if you can embrace
the mess it can really help you
we're used to most of us solving
problems in a very logical and linear
way and that's easy to project manage
and control and to protect the outputs
of
however for complex problems it doesn't
always work
so design thinking is focused it's just
it's focused on impact
rather than output and there's a big
difference um
so the process isn't exactly linear
although it's broadly
linear but it allows you therefore to
navigate the complexity and we have to
also bear in mind as i mentioned earlier
humans aren't logical so trying to apply
a very linear logical approach
to everything we do when we design for
humans may mean it doesn't always work
the way we would like
us to and then finally i don't know
where to start
that's where design singapore can help
so michelle will share more with you in
a moment
and i've mentioned school of ex please
do feel free to get in touch on that
i'm just gonna very quickly before i end
uh
share with you a quick case study we
have many case studies and i thought
this was a nice quick one some of you
may be aware of it
um this was cheng yoo-heng yeah
a sugar candy company so they were back
in the early 2010s they were
one of singapore's largest rock sugar
manufacturers yeah
and you may have heard or read about
this case study already in the press
they started to find that the market was
becoming more challenging
um cheaper alternatives of their rock
sugar were coming in from other parts of
the region
and actually on the consumer side they
found that traditional rock sugar was
facing a decline there was less consumer
demand for it so they step back and try
to work out what they might do about
that
so um the the head of business
development there
john chang here he is a young guy i
think only 26 when he embarked on this
journey
actually became inspired by design
thinking and wanted to understand if
this might be part of an opportunity for
their
for their new approach so as well as
hiring external business consultants
they brought design thinking into their
approach
they tried to explore what might be
different and they used design
ethnography to better understand what
customers were looking for to better
understand pain points and also
the opportunity they they identified
that the younger audience
might be their new target segment
so they worked with different
universities and
polytechnics in singapore and they
developed a new methodology
for a different way of crystallizing
rock sugar on sticks and you've probably
seen these now in the shops
um but also to infuse that rock sugar
with different colors and flavors so it
became a very different product from
what
they've been traditionally selling they
tasted the prototypes get feedback and
found
that it had multiple uses the way what
they observed was the way that people
using the crystal
sugar on the sticks was as a candy with
flavor and also to stir into their
drinks which stirred the drink
added flavor added sweetness and they
suddenly started to see that they had a
whole new opportunity on their hands
so having run these design focus groups
these sessions
they actually didn't just look at the
product they looked at the entire
consumer experience around the rock
sugar sticks
so they wanted to package it in such a
way that was exciting and engaging to
their younger audience
but also to encourage people to really
experience to have a journey
the with the crystal sugar yeah so to
taste it to mix it to taste it again to
see how that changes
they looked at collaborations for
example this one with clipper tea
whereby you can use
different flavored uh jewel sticks with
different flavor teas to have different
experiences so they've really created an
expanded brand new product line
experience and i have to tell you my
little boy is a massive fan of theirs
um but this wasn't just a nice to have
they actually saw huge business growth
as a result of that
so they've seen uh the revenue has seen
three digit growth
since since they launched the duals back
in 2016. um
uh but there's also the fact that
actually it's far more consumer
awareness about the product and about
this this kind of um
rock sugar market it allowed them also
to enter a different geographical market
they'd always struggle to get into the
chinese supermarkets
but now with this new type of product
they found they had a different
breakthrough
so um they say apparently today they now
have around 60
of market share of rock sugar in
singapore so despite the fact with
all our concerns about health and
diabetes
they found that actually as part of a
balanced diet they've seen that their
business is still growing
so in difficult environment and
difficult conditions they've been able
to buck that trend
so this is just an example of how one
local firm has been able to
really infuse design thinking into their
approach and see very different results
from that so i'm going to pause because
i know i think i've run out of time
and but please do feel free to ask me
questions i can't see the chat box right
now but i'll stop
sharing and then i can see if there's
any questions you have thank you
everyone
thank you tamzin thanks for their very
lively
sharing so like what what tamzin
mentioned um
design thinking can be even used for
commodities like sugar
so in a nutshell design thinking is
useful because it can help to improve
customer experience and like you've seen
from the
previous examples it can help you pivot
your business into adjacent markets
and also sharpen and improve brand
positioning even helping you to go
digital
and building capabilities so uh
you in the process of doing design
thinking again you have deeper
understanding of your user needs as well
as behaviors
like what tamzin has mentioned earlier
there's different lengths that you take
on
to build a more holistic understanding
of where your situation or the context
is
and also in the process you the risk
information
and safe cause and expedite the whole
development
process so we have like time to mention
we have two schemes
developed in collaboration with
enterprise singapore for companies who
wish to start using design to transform
their businesses
um two of them one is user journey
mapping
the other one is frame and school where
companies can
receive up to eighty percent uh so the
first one
as the name suggests it gives companies
an actual
customer journey map as a deliverable i
will show you how that looks like in a
bit
so this map uh helps you evaluate the
entire process of how users are
interacting with your brand the positive
as well as the negative experiences
the good and bad touch points we have in
total
three different options um i will share
with you later
so you'll be thinking how can your
company start to use this right
what kind of problems can you use it for
so here are some of the examples of the
problem statements that
we see uh companies um onboarding
onboarding the scheme uh
what they put out there as challenge
statements how might
um we improve the digital learning
experience of cooking academy
in in given current times who are the
key segments of the business
that the business should target and then
how can we improve
overall in-store experience for example
so in this slide um okay i just go back
to that slide
this is how the user journey mapping
looks like it starts
with um starts by compiling a series of
user actions and goals
into a timeline and then fleshed out
with thoughts
as well as emotions to create um a
narrative
so then this narrative is put out in in
this visual format
so you you'll see in this example which
is much more fleshed out
it focuses on one on a customer's
experience
how he or she is going about their
in-store food ordering experience
from pre-ordering stage all the way to
post-consumption stage
so uh you'll be able to see like oh this
office lady is
feeling very stressed out you know and
in uh in the midst of a busy working
schedule she's trying to find
somewhere else to relax and have lunch
so these are
various opportunities and touch points
that the business can
look into to improve and and find ways
to to reach out to customers
in in this slide um we have a study
done by aberdeen in 2016
so it was reported that companies who
invest
invested in customer journey management
they they see
um on average of 54 greater marketing
returns than those who didn't
there were also more cross sells and
upsell revenues
and faster than average sales cycle
so going proper into the scheme user
journey mapping
we have depending on your budget and
appetite we are offering three different
variations of the ujms to companies
uh in all of these options you get to
work with design consultants from a
panel
of your preferred choice so basically
the
the three options they vary in the
extent of how much
and how deep you want to go so think of
it as small medium large
options in option one uh it's for
companies
uh companies facing comp customer facing
companies
who would want a quick understanding of
their current customer journey so this
focuses on one persona
that's why it's a very light touch kind
of approach whereas in option two
more slightly more extensive we will
cover up to three to four personas
so this would be useful for businesses
who are thinking of reaching out to new
potential customer segments for your
products or services
and in option three apart from surveying
your
customers aka your external stakeholders
this option will also take you through
your internal customers which is your
stuff how the backend operations and
everything
link up and ultimately affect your front
end um customer experience
so if you want to put it out in a very
visual format this is uh
the differences between the various
options option one and two
more front stage thing where you you
know interact with your customers
and option three is a full full-blown
service
design blueprint that will map out back
end all the way to front
uh front stage in the next
scheme that i'll share it's called frame
and scope basically
this is for companies with a larger
appetite using a similar but more
extensive process
um helping companies identify and
prioritize key areas of transformation
and then um outlining a roadmap of
implementations for them so far we have
about
11 companies who have bombarded this
scheme with us of which
two of them have already completed the
initial phase
we have two of them here to share with
us today you'll hear from them shortly
so here's an example of some of the
project statements that they come
with how how might they want to engage
the millennials to create a new
experience beyond selling products how
do you create
a experience strategy to you know target
your affluent customers
basically fns frame and scope is a
deeper level of exploration
and understanding of possible new
business opportunities
or areas of transformation it is a
slightly longer program you can see from
the timeline broken down to two key
phases
in phase one the the first phase will be
uh supported
and funded by a design council the
second phase by enterprise singapore
companies in the first phase companies
will go through a discover and
prioritize phase
uh where at the end of it they'll
receive um
sort of like a strategy roadmap
outlining possible
uh recommendations as well as
implementations so
uh with this um document companies can
use it
to further fine-tune their thinking on
on projects they have in mind
with renewed clarity and focus and with
the help of
design consultants who who they will
choose from the panel companies can then
draft a proposal
to esg enterprise singapore and then
proceed to
phase two to acquire more funding from
esg for
implementation course once the grant
proposal is approved
so i wouldn't go too much in detail but
in a nutshell
basically these two schemes if you want
to compare
you ujm user journey mapping is a low
touch approach for companies
wanting to quickly zoom in on certain
areas of their business to
improve upon whereas frame and scope is
useful for companies
who are not quite sure what what is the
problem they want to solve
quite similar to what tamzin has
mentioned earlier as well it provides
clarity to help you solve the right
problem because sometimes
you might be solving the wrong problem
and so frame and scope gives you the
opportunity to
to properly frame and and identify which
are the opportunity areas that you
should be addressing
so with that i will um hand the session
now
over to uh zad young from photohub
who will be sharing um how they found
the schemes useful over to you that
young
okay firstly uh i'd like to share a word
of thanks to
um uh design singapore and sbf
you know for providing this platform to
share a little bit on our
company's transformation journey okay
my name is uh
just a minute this slide is uh
okay my name is stan leon i i take care
of the uh corporate planning and
development aspects
of my company photohub
we were established in 1987 about 33
years ago
as a small photo clean shop located at
the
coronation plaza that's along bukit
timah road
so uh the picture you see there that's
our very first shop so
if you look closely at the picture uh
you will notice
we carry a lot of codecs uh products and
services
in fact 90 or more of our products and
services comes from
kodak the founders uh
vincent and eric uh if they look
uh alike to you yeah uh you're right
yeah they're twins you know
so in the uh growing up years and even
of now you know they uh
have lots of interesting experiences uh
on the
mistaken identities but i guess that's
another story for another day
now uh for photo hub
we are often seen as a sunset
industry so let me just illustrate a
little bit
um when kodak
example you know uh collapse and file
for
bankruptcy in 2012 a lot of people think
you know uh yeah
photo hub probably gonna be under the
water pretty soon as well
you know but fortunately we didn't okay
even as of today uh if we look at our
business
you know uh we go ask around or we ask
ourselves
when was the last time we print some
photos most of us will probably say
oh i can't remember that was a long time
ago
so we are often seen as a
sunset industry um but the strange part
is
uh this sunset you know for a great part
of the
33 years we are seen as a sunset
industry
but the interesting part is you know uh
the sun is still setting
um and uh haven't quite set yet
now um because why if we look closely at
our company we don't just actually
print photos we also do you know we have
expanded innovators you know
our business to also do
a very high-end professional grade
scanning uh digitization
and archiving of heritage materials
classified confidential documents you
know
so today uh some of the clients that we
have
that we count you know as our clients
include the uh
national library board uh national
archives of singapore
prime minister's office um corporate
clients we have you know like
architectural firms
like um
american club you know for clubs uh so
the least
basically uh goes on
so our business is not just in photo
prints
you know we are actually you know today
a
total imaging solutions provider
and how do we do that
for us we are a firm believer of
constant innovation constantly
constantly transforming ourselves
you know not just only to
stay relevant with the times but in fact
you know
to stay ahead of the curve uh to future
proof ourselves
you know to be always future
ready
our challenges
now if you look at our industry now
with the advances in uh mobile
uh digital technology mobile phone
technology
the technologies that goes into the
cameras in our phones
the memory size you know of our phone
you know they
are they are you know advancing in leaps
and bounds
so accordingly if you look at the images
that exist you know and circulate around
the world today
you know it has grown exponentially you
know compared to
33 years ago when we first started photo
out
so if you look at it from that
perspective then
actually um the pie
you know uh the market is much bigger
than it used to be but our challenge is
this
our challenge is how to get people
to convert these images into
so basically how to you know get people
to rediscover the joy of prince
we were very fortunate during one of our
meetings uh
sessions with enterprise singapore you
know
when we're sharing a bit of our
aspirations you know dreams
plans and the challenges you know uh
they share with us they say hey you know
why don't you all look into this
design thinking for best better business
program
that is being uh conducted by design
singapore we say ah
was that you know but we kept an open
mind
so uh enterprise singapore did the link
up you know
so we the uh design singapore
you know uh team came down spoke to us
um and they were very helpful they
listened to us
they basically understand our needs our
challenges you know
what we are facing and what they did
next was you know they
um after sharing uh
about their program helping us to
understand what they can do for us
they went to go about
you know uh sourcing for consultants
shortlisted them and let us do our
interview
to select them so eventually we found a
very good consultant
we started our project in uh
mid march this year and uh
uh eventually it was completed in end
september took a bit longer than
expected but we all know why
uh it's because of the uh the kovite 19
the pandemic and the circuit breaker
measures but
with the benefit of hindsight you know
we're glad
it uh took the time that it did because
why
in the final report that we have the
roadmap that we have you know
uh it also take into consideration you
know
uh some of the things that we need to do
in uh what is the likely you know
post pandemic kind of landscape is gonna
be like
so yes uh it has been a good exercise
for us
so we are thankful to design singapore
uh
in fact for photo hub you know uh
being in touch with them has been the
one of the key highlights for the uh
motorhome calendar this year yeah
now uh i'm not privy to share a lot of
the details the
you know the the more confidential
details of the uh report you know
uh but these are some of the things that
we
are looking forward to excitedly on how
our
maybe uh future you know uh outlets that
uh will look and feel like and uh of
course there's a lot more details into
it so
uh that's just a bit of the visuals
yeah um so we basically can't wait to
get this started and i think on that
note uh
thanks if there's any questions i'll be
happy to take them later
uh back to you uh michelle
thank you tad young thanks for sharing i
think normal hair from richard from the
pro group to share his experience
great thanks for the introduction
michelle hi my name is richard lowe the
ceo and co-founder of plo
we're a niche luxury betting and brand
headquartered here in singapore
and we primarily work with uh luxury
hospitality clients around the world to
help them deliver their sleep and math
experiences for their guests
our philosophy is about focus that is
doing only a few things but doing it
very very well
and in terms of product uh we offer
goose down pillows
uh like you see behind me uh duvets
egyptian cotton bed linens
plush toweling and robes under our plow
brand
and this is a brand that we created is
actually uh
comprises our family name low and just
to play on the words pillow
so over the years we've been fortunate
to become the betting brand of choice
for many luxury properties around the
world and our clients now include
properties like the amman in tokyo the
mandarin oriental in paris or london or
new york
the taj mahal in mumbai and also right
here in singapore
the raffle singapore an iconic property
so as michelle had stated we were one of
the early companies
which embarked on this dsg frame and
scope initiative
and i just wanted to take this time to
share some of our experience and
thoughts about it with all of you
so let me start by just providing a
little context then share a little bit
more about what the project did for us
and finally leave you with a few
thoughts for consideration if you
you yourselves decide to embark on the
program
so in terms of providing some context
back in
2002 when we founded the company our
vision was to build a world-class
business and brand and that was focused
on the luxury sleep and bath space
and it still is and for the first 16
plus years we were keenly focused
on building a world-class brand but
particularly in the b
to b the hospitality space and ecosystem
over the last 18 months however when we
were doing some strategic
planning and asking ourselves how do we
grow
how do we evolve the company we realized
one important thing
it was what got us here will not
necessarily get us there
uh we thought this because we saw that
the world was rapidly
changing our clients were evolving
industry consolidation was taking place
in our sector
for example a lot of the big hotel
groups were buying out each other
and thus changing the dynamics of how
they were going about
business buying things prioritizing
things and going to market
at the same time however there were also
a lot of exciting developments
on the consumer side taking place there
were a lot more people
having been in business now for 16 17
years
that were experiencing the plo brand at
top hotels around the world
there was also a lot more focus in the
marketplace about good sleep and the
importance of
getting good sleep and what it could do
for you
the wellness wellness movement was
taking place
and most exciting of all was the rapidly
growing middle and affluent class here
in southeast asia and the growth of
e-commerce
right in our backyard if some of you
have um
read some of those recent reports by
tomasik google and bain
about you know southeast asia being the
third largest uh
e-commerce market and also the fastest
growing we saw those as exciting things
for our business and our brand
and this is precisely where design comes
in and actually design thinking
for us we were looking to answer the
following question
given the increasingly recognized
program we had managed to build in the
b2b space which was the hospitality in
the hotel space
how do we now digitalize
and deploy that pro brand in the direct
consumer space
that was our new journey and intent
and so that's what we use the frame and
scope project to help us think through
that question
and to explore it more fully from a
design thinking perspective
so if i have to answer the question so
how did the dsg
frame and scope program help us i think
the most important thing was
it helped us clarify thinking on several
fronts
first it confirmed our key questions the
issues the assumptions we wanted to
address
um it also better ensured that we were
asking the right question for the
situation i think you heard tamzin
mention
about the importance of asking the right
question
and clarifying that um
it also helped us you know think about
the possibilities
and be more clear about the outcomes and
the intent that we wanted to have
for us uh it was a question you know how
do we digitalize and deploy our brand to
the direct consumer globally
not only did the six eight week project
help us
to do that but it also clarified our
path forward
it also reminded us to have a keen focus
on the consumer to be consumer-centric
and it helped us act on our intent to
enhance the flow customer experience
for that direct customer and at all
lastly it also helped us think about our
growth
where we wanted to grow what we wanted
to do better
who we wanted to reach out more
specifically basically it helped us to
frame that challenge and that
opportunity secondly how did it help us
practically it also provided us some
financial and advisory support for
something that we already wanted to do
this was we started the program in april
this year
but this was a question that we'd
already been thinking about and we've
been interviewing
consultants beforehand um
on the third thing it helped us to do
was that it helped introduce us to a
global design ecosystem and network
and this was through the through dsg and
just being part of the program
uh one of the interesting things was
that we were asked to participate in the
mckinsey design
index baseline survey where your answers
are benchmarked against
uh world-class uh global companies that
are already incorporating design about
their strategic
plans and initiatives so what we got to
see is that where we would
where our thinking stood relative to how
others who are the best in
in class go about incorporating
design into their thinking
so those those were three ways that
how the the program helped us
first it clarified our thinking it
provided us the financial
um actually support and it also
introduced us a global design ecosystem
and network
what i'd like to do now is just to share
a few thoughts um
about the our takeaways from the program
and maybe it's it'll help you as you
think through whether it's something
appropriate for you
one thing was that focusing on the
customer experience journey can bear a
lot of fruit
we use customer oriented surveys
interviews and questions to elicit a lot
of important insights about our brand
and also what resonated with our
customers we hadn't done that
with our global base of customers in a
long time
we're also exposed to new frameworks on
which to better think through the
problem
the situation the opportunities at hand
we also
introduced the concept of the job to be
done what is the job that we do for our
customers
what do they buy us for to accomplish it
was a
it was a good way of just thinking uh
focusing back on the customer
a second thing that i would like to
share is that the importance of
continuously evolving
remember what i mentioned earlier is
that what you got what got you here will
not necessarily get you there
um as a business as an sme we're all on
a journey
different journeys of course to
different destinations
in different contexts and for different
outcomes and as we're all experiencing
the world is continuing to change at an
ever increasing speed
the rules are changing leaders are
changing
markets get disrupted and even pandemics
are coming along like covid which has
upended many plans
and continues to do so that change is
affecting our respective journeys
increasingly so there are many new
normals emerging and
to be prepared for and what we found is
that design thinking gives us the
mindset
and a good set of tools and an approach
to help us continuously evolve
and innovate as a business and a brand
um another lesson learned was to
choose your consultant and advisory team
carefully
this needs to be someone on or a team
who can really understand your business
your context and your objectives
but also challenge you with new
frameworks and perspectives
and yet also do it in a way and and
communicate with you in a way that
you your senior management team can hear
we had actually spoken with about four
to five uh different firms before we'd
even met up with dsg
and after meeting up with dsg they
recommended four
or five more firms that we could speak
to
we went ahead to do that and actually
the process of speaking with the
consultants
is valuable in itself as it forces you
to clarify and frame the situation
you find yourself in and to scope out
the coverage that you need
overall you know we we're very happy we
had a great
consultant team uh we kicked off
uh just a few days before phase one
lockdown
so we actually completed our whole
project
through zoom meetings uh
workshops interviews all through zoom
the last thing i'd like to share is that
if
if you do plan to go ahead and
embark on this program is is to use the
opportunity as a
as used a project as an opportunity to
raise your game as a business
um basically to do better for your
customers
and raise the game that you play for
them because they will reward you with
more business
um that said you know if and this is to
all those who are here on this webinar
if you're
wondering how you want to reach an
evolving customer in the new normal
this could be the right program to help
you plan your approach
if you're in the wholesale or services
business and wondering how to reposition
your company amidst all the changes
taking place in respective industries
this could be an excellent uh project
for you to help you think through what
can be done
um or if you're in retail if you're
looking to simply see how you can bring
more value to a customer who now has
many more
options and to deliver something more
than what your customer
or your competitor offers sorry this
project could be valuable to you
overall for us the project was very
practical and also tangible
um we were reimbursed promptly too
uh once the deliverables were completed
uh
the financial support is significant but
more so the strategic support and
internal skill building and exposure to
the design ecosystem
was invaluable um
that basically wraps up my comments
about the dsg
frame and scope experience and i hope it
will provide you some
good input for thought thank you
yeah so if you want to uh scan the qr
code to download the slides and also to
indicate your interest in the scheme so
having heard from richard as well as
that long if you still have any more
questions feel free to ask us
um now if not you can also separately
email
us um i just like to put the
session back to the speakers as well as
to tamzin anything else that you would
like to
to ask each other about you know in
terms of design process maybe
a question from bishop for example
you're mentioning about the
the building of the skills transfer
within the team
how can you elaborate a little bit about
how that process looked like for you
between plo and the design consultant
oh i think it was just being exposed to
the design thinking framework as tamsen
had mentioned there's many different
frameworks
uh but just having that mindset and
thinking in that approach
it's uh coming at it from a
human-centered approach
and it's basically uh problem solving
and using the tools that a designer
typically brings to a situation
um and for us it was just realizing how
important it was to
to put the customer at the forefront and
to
think of it from their perspective and
just doing so
gave us a lot of a lot of discussion and
this
way of thinking that it was like not
giving us a fish but giving us
teaching us how to fish so i think that
was that was quite powerful and what our
team uh really appreciated
and of course there's there's many
different um
uh frameworks that i think probably
tamzin can
share more about thank you
yeah there are many and very often
before i joined design singapore council
i was a lecturer
at national university of singapore and
before people came on the programs they
would often say which framework
you're going to teach and i say it
doesn't matter i teach whichever
framework you want because
actually the process is the same it's
about some fundamental principles
and i always say you don't need to be a
slave to the framework it's designed to
help you to get from one place to
another
um quite powerfully some people have
been asking questions earlier and i
i think um some of that was quite
interesting as well talking about for
example the
construction industry and whether
whether design thinking is relevant in
sectors like that i
i can say that i've applied design
thinking in many
sectors um before i came to design
singapore council i ran something called
the smart health leadership center at
nus
that looked at how we transform the
experience of health care and social
services
in a kind of integrated way so that's a
very complex domain
where we can apply it prior to moving
singapore as i mentioned i worked on a
huge civil engineering project with
um i think we had about five thousand
personnel working on that site
many different subcontractors so design
thinking was infused throughout that
project but the big secret is we never
called it design thinking
because none of my engineers would have
been brought into that and certainly
none of my muddy booted construction
workers would have
but actually what they were interested
in was getting rid of hassle and
focusing on doing the job
because if construction project goes
behind time there are big penalties to
pay usually
so they were interested in the results
and when they started to get the results
they were interested in doing more of
what they called the communication stuff
yeah
call it what you like and i'm absolutely
fine with that i don't care which
framework it is or which tool it's
actually about building those principles
into the process
and as the results come along you find
it really
grows
yeah i could ramble on for ages but i
feel my voice dominates so i'll
let someone else speak
do we have a great husband say if anyone
else has questions
or does um does richard and do you have
any additional
word of advice for companies who are
contemplating on making a move on these
schemes
i mean the the barrier to to to going on
board some of these schemes can be quite
real i think
maybe helping to articulate that to some
the businesses here would help
uh if i may uh
uh actually when we were when we first
heard of this game we were
honestly not too sure what to expect of
it you know
and but uh like i said earlier as well
eventually after going through it
and and we are glad we actually kept a
very open mind and
we are glad we went through it you know
because after going through it
we realized that hey you know especially
with the road map done already a lot of
things that we were thinking our mind
maybe we should do this maybe we should
do that it kind of help us
crystallize a lot of things you know and
uh
not not only that the non-crystallized a
lot of things that we
thought uh yeah should be done this way
or that way you know
but also help us you know discovered a
lot of new things
as well so like i i was sharing our
challenges
our challenges one of the biggest
challenges we have
is how to get people to read discover
the joy of friends you know
so we have been uh that has been on our
mind for the longest time
uh we thought we have some answers but
we couldn't quite get there but
after going through the workshop you
know uh
i think uh we feel much more confident
now so we kind of like you know uh
sharing
like i was sharing a bit earlier can't
wait to get this uh thing started
so so basically that's that's how we
feel
yeah so um for companies out there
um my thinking is this you know uh
no harm keeping an open mind you know uh
uh just listen you know and who knows
you know
uh there'll probably be some things uh
you know uh
you got lots more to gain if it works
out and in our case it works out and it
works out
uh pretty very well actually yeah
yeah and if i could add just briefly i
would definitely encourage uh
companies all companies to take
advantage of this this is something
that's quite
unique and not many
countries or governments or agencies
offer this
and if you were already thinking of you
know your strategy
going forward how do you want to remain
resonant or relevant to your customers
sign up for this program because i think
it's
it's it's subsidized but it also as i
mentioned you know
it uh introduces you to a whole design
ecosystem
uh design will play a very important
role of of uh
singapore's development uh in the
economy
um as uh tamzin had mentioned that
design master plan 2025
um i just think it's a it's a no-brainer
to
to tap into this actually our overall
experience has exceeded expectations
and as i mentioned we've done we did
pretty much the whole project except for
the kickoff uh through zoom
uh but what really impressed me was that
um
the dsg uh people we had worked with
uh gabriel and his team actually were
there on the calls with us
uh just all the way through and also
asking for feedback
and you know if some of you thinking is
there a lot of bureaucracy or red tape
associated with this actually i'd like
to say surprisingly not
and um i
joked with the tsg team is that
i think they probably went through they
used the design thinking process to
think through
how to better serve the customer which
is the smes like us
you know to to make it a much more
seamless
um convenient but also much more
uh customer friendly process so
yeah i i would uh highly recommend it
actually i i kind of agree with you more
richard uh
i think as an sme i i think we are quite
blessed to be in singapore yeah
we truly are yeah
i want you to just follow up very sorry
sorry michelle very grateful
and something you've mentioned there we
can't wait to get started and i think
for everyone that gives into the process
actually they all reach that point and
it's that amazing thing because the
process
isn't what you're used to yet it's not
normally the way we we come up with new
products or solutions
and it can feel at times and maybe in
the early stages a little bit uncertain
[Music]
but then it's that wonderful moment you
get that point oh and that excitement
actually is palpable
and it's for me very rewarding when i
see teams i've worked with have come
from diverse backgrounds and also
sometimes quite cynical
is this really going to work can it
really work women building prototypes
out of cardboard boxes and lego
pieces but actually it's that amazing
moment they get to
think wow it actually is going to work
and we get to roll it out
it's phenomenal so it's nice to hear
that actually what you've said there
yeah yeah actually it is we truly feel
that way
and if i can maybe share a little bit
more than you know um
when we were yeah first of all i like to
say thanks to gabriel and everybody you
know so
uh they have been very supportive and
they've been very helpful
you know so so uh yeah we we owe them
lots of tanks you know and uh
when we eventually found the consultant
that we have uh
uh pardon the description you know we
chose the consultancy company i think
that gives us a perfect fit but when
they give
us the elite consultant the lead
consultant was there are more
a caucasian so basically
now our problem is most of our
staff in our company they are chinese
speaking
so my worry is the communication issue
you know uh but thanks to the consultant
you know and his team as well
they have been a very patient you know
and
uh it has been very understanding and at
the end of the day you know uh
after we've gone through the whole thing
we are quite glad that he stayed with us
you know and
and he didn't change you know so so it
was a very fruitful
exercise yeah yeah yes that that that
echoes uh
my guidance or my listener you know
choose the consultant carefully
someone that not only fits but also
pushes you but
communicates it in the right way
on that note maybe can i ask both of you
um what is the difference between
working with a design consultant versus
a business consultant i mean
both of you must have worked with
business consultants before right but
this is probably one of the
the rare or few times that you you both
embark on
working with a design consultant
[Music]
uh i'll take a stab at that one i think
i mean
i think that all consultants are there
to help to
problem solve and to find appropriate
solutions
uh i think just
the the design consultant comes with
maybe one more
um one more toolbox
and that is the design toolbox uh
that's that's based in innovation but
has some different tools compared to the
typical business school approach
i was a former consultant as well and
but the design thinking framework or
just the design thinking approach
human centered using different tools
and coming at it perhaps from an
experience perspective
or an emotional perspective
goes a long way
i mean i'm dying to know from both of
you which
part of the process did you find
yourself feeling most cynical about
because there must have been those
little moments of cynicism thing yeah is
this
really going to work or were you very
open actually you sound both very open
but i'm quite curious about that
yeah actually uh for us
uh plo we were actually very open
because uh we had already
uh a few years ago we had been uh
exposed to you know the power of design
through brainstorm
design we attended a brainstorm design
the first one in 2018 and also 2019 and
and watching all those um business
leaders from around the world
uh design practitioners architects
designers
talking about the the power of bringing
design and business together
uh we got very excited and so we had
already embarked on
on talking to some of those design
consultants
and then only later we met up with dsg
and then when we found out that wow they
were offering a program they were
helping to subsidize certain things we
said you know please sign us up so you
were up for it anyway yeah so you've
yeah
we were already gonna do it yeah yeah
yeah excellent
actually the same for us as well yeah
and uh
about the cynicism part of it is um
i i described it as one of the sessions
that we have you know with
at that point in time we're about 50 you
know halfway through
the uh the the project already and then
i described it
the this way at one of the meetings i
think gabriel
gabriel might have been there i i'm not
too sure i said uh
i said at the meeting i said you know
when we first started on this journey
we didn't quite know what to expect you
know and i describe it this way you just
imagine ourselves
waking up you know uh at about five a.m
in the morning you know and we are going
to go
uh to this outfield camp you know uh our
fuel exercise
and then when you get into the field you
see oh it's all
dark and misty and you know it is cold
and
it feels good that miserable kind of a
feeling
and don't what to expect but as we
progresses you know and then
and the the sun starts to rise a bit and
you can see a bit of the silhouette the
trees and
the mist start to clear the dampness
start to clear uh that's a pretty good
feeling
you know and i said hey this is
beginning to look uh
interesting and then of course you know
eventually we saw the sunrise and
and it was really great yeah i think
that's a brilliant
articulation of the process that is it
we start to
we start to eventually see the the
camera lens focus and go oh
okay but yeah i think they really said
that
anyway yeah thank you so much
um for sharing i think i'm conscious of
time as well so is there
further questions from the floor or
amongst the panelists
if not we will we will call this a rep
and then if you know please help us to
scan the qr code provide your feedback
we'd love to make this session more
relevant and more useful for the
businesses and for yourselves
and feel free to reach out to you know
the emails you see on the screen or to
tamzin or to richard as well as start
long if you have
further questions we'll be following up
with the post event edm
so um highlighting all this the salient
points has been discussed
um in in this session so and also um
a link to download the slides as well so
any more last questions if not thank you
so much for
everyone's time today and also thank you
to sbf for
um working and collaborating with design
singapore to put this session together
for everyone
um this afternoon thank you
thank you thank you so much